well the incident happened around
halfway between the Kent coast and the
coast of France Sky News understands the
boat set off from amble to's Beach just
Southwest of Calais the alarm was raised
just after three o'clock this morning
two Search and Rescue helicopters plus a
french navy helicopter rnli lifeboats
and other UK and French Navy boats were
all involved in the rescue
our home editor Jason Farrell has
tonight's first report on this morning's
rescue operation under warning it does
include pictures of the dead body of one
of the victims
foreign
has collapsed the people inside are
immersed in freezing water their lives
in the balance
salvation is a hundred foot scallop boat
called Arcturus every face is focused on
the rope that could save them if they
could just reach it
photos capture the horror people up to
their necks in water the man in blue at
the back barely hanging on
and some had left away from the dean
screaming for help
you can see in the bottom right corner
of this shot two people hardly able to
keep their heads above water
a fisherman Raymond was among those
rescuing the migrants and he spoke
exclusively to us from his boat on the
phone the second condition was going to
represent the series
still was really easy
[Music]
for all these people that were screaming
it didn't feel real was this borders
everywhere at all road reports five six
people each side we were all time to get
aboard the other fishing gear and tell
them a crew don't let me go please help
the Royal Navy french navy Coast Guard
and rnli lifeboats helped in ensuring
the last survivors were plucked from the
sea Guided by helicopter spotlights
above it's rare that a rescue is
documented in this detail and the Grim
reality is also captured by the
fisherman's camera showing that not
everyone made it
this man had attached himself to the
side of Raymond's boat out of sight
until it was too late
you can almost feel the ice cold
temperatures of just one degree Celsius
just looking at the images of those who
made it on board
if you do it too quickly it could be a
heart attack after Raymond and his crew
had pulled the people out of the water
and given them a warm shower and warm
clothes they realized they had 31 people
on board and what's clear now is that if
Ray's Boat hadn't been in the right
place at the right time many if not all
of those people would have died in the
water
but those warnings and these images
don't seem to deter nearly 45
000 people have crossed the channel this
year and many more will try
Jason Farrell Sky News Dover